انضم إلينا للحديث أكثر عن
جهود البحث وما نأمل أن يكون في مرحلة ما
جهود إنقاذ، يسعدنا أن يكون كابتن البحرية المتقاعد
تشيب ماكورد في خدمتك يا
سيدي، وأتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكانك مساعدتنا في
فهم
أهمية الضوضاء التي نعرفها كما نعرفها.
تم سماعها حتى الآن
لأنه إذا استمعت إلى
المؤتمر الصحفي لخفر السواحل في وقت سابق اليوم،
فإنهم يقولون بكلمات كثيرة أنهم لا
يعرفون حقًا ما هي الضوضاء،
ويأملون أن يصفهم البعض بأنهم
ضجيجًا على الرغم من أن كابتن خفر السواحل
لم يكن كذلك.  غير متأكد من أن هذا ما لم يكن
مؤكدًا أيضًا الإطار الزمني كما هو موضح هل
كان كل 30 دقيقة أو أي
إطار زمني آخر غير محدد بناءً على ما
سمعته هل تعتقد أن لديهم
اتصال محتمل موثوق به مع
الغواصة المفقودة
أه جيم أنا  أعتقد أنني سأتفق مع
كابتن خفر السواحل الذي يقول إنهم
لا يعرفون بالضبط ما لديهم، لذا أعتقد أنني
سأترك الأمر عند هذا الحد،
فهم جميعًا هناك ينظرون إليه
ويمكننا وضع بعض التخمينات فيه  لكن
اه إذا كانوا يعرفون على وجه اليقين أنه كان
شخصًا يطرق حفرة باستخدام SOS اه
فلن يعرفوا لذلك أعتقد أن
لديهم الآن الإجابة وهي بالنسبة لنا
هنا أنهم لا يعرفون حقًا ما
لديهم حسنًا و  هذا مهم
لإدارة التوقعات ولكن
من الواضح أنه أفضل ما لديهم، لذلك
لديك هذا المؤشر هنا غير محدد، حيث
تستخدم كل ما تستطيع في
ما هي المرحلة الآن التي ستظل
تستمع إليها من خلال
طائرات الصيد الفرعية الفعالة
يوجد أيضًا سونار للمسح الجانبي في p3s وp8s، هل
يمكنك البحث في منطقة تبلغ مساحتها ضعف مساحة
ولاية كونيتيكت بسرعة للوصول
إلى شيء مثل هذا،
لا أعتقد أنهم يحتاجون حقًا إلى
الجزء الموجود تحت الماء للبحث عنه
المنطقة ضعف حجم ولاية كونيتيكت هناك
ربما
أه ربما لا تزيد عن ميل أو
ميلين في ميلين في الأسفل وهو على
الأرجح المكان الذي من
المرجح أن تكون فيه الغواصة ليست على
السطح أو أعتقد أنه كان من الممكن أن
يكون  تم رصده ومن
المستبعد جدًا جدًا أن يكون موجودًا في عمود الماء
بين القاع والسطح، لذا على
الأرجح أنه في القاع
ومرة ​​أخرى، التيارات ليست
كبيرة هنا بالأسفل، لذا على الأرجح أنها
قريبة جدًا من المنطقة التي
نزلت إليها
مثيرة للاهتمام، لذا فإن
منطقة البحث هذه هي منطقة البحث السطحية التي
تقولها بناءً على ما
يعرفون أنه
يمكنهم فعله على الأرجح وأنا أعلم أنه
لا يوجد يقين هنا ولكن ولكن مع
تضييق منطقة البحث إلى حد كبير إلى
بضعة أميال إذا كان ذلك  في هذه الحالة،
ما مدى سرعة البحث في تلك المنطقة،
مساحة كبيرة، إنها مساحة كبيرة على
السطح نظرًا لوجود تيارات ومد وجزر على السطح،
لذا لو كانت على
السطح لكانت طفت على
القاع ولن تطفو
هناك و  هل هذا يعتمد على ما تعرفه
على الأرجح أن هذا الشيء موجود في
الأسفل بدلاً من أن يطفو في منتصف الطريق للأعلى
أو على السطح أوه بالتأكيد نعم بالتأكيد
وأه
سبب بقائه في الأسفل هو
أنك تعلم أنه ربما تعرض لعطل كهربائي
ربما لم يكن قادرًا على
تفريغ ثقل الصابورة عليه لمساعدته على الرفع،
ربما يكون عالقًا تحت شيء ما أو
ربما يكون قد سحق، كما تعلم، كان هناك
عطل هيكلي،
حسنًا إذا لم يتم سحقه وإذا كانت لا
تزال مساحة صالحة للعيش هناك،
فيمكن  لقد طرحته، أعني أنه
سؤال عملي للغاية، هل يمكنك ذلك، وإذا كنت تستطيع،
ما مدى سرعة ذلك،
حسنًا، فالبحرية الأمريكية الموجودة هناك
تشرف على ضباط الإنقاذ
هناك، ولديهم خبرة في القيام بذلك
والكثير من الخبرة في
السنوات القليلة الماضية  لقد استعادوا طائرة F-35 من عمق
12500 قدم من الماء،
وهي طائرة مقاتلة وطائرة هليكوبتر من طراز mh-60
من عمق 19000 قدم من الماء، لذا فقد
بنوا طائرات بشكل أساسي كانت
سليمة واستعادوها، وهم
لا يفعلون ذلك عادةً  يسيرون بسرعة كبيرة عندما
يفعلون ذلك، ولا يسيرون ببطء لأنهم ليسوا موجودين،
ولا توجد عادةً
حالة لشخص ما على قيد الحياة فيما
يتعافون منه،
ولذا فهي عملية خطوة بخطوة جدًا
أه الطريقة التي يفعلون بها ذلك هي أنهم
يبحثون
عن العنصر الذي يبحثون عنه
والذي يعد مرة أخرى المفتاح في هذه الحالة
الآن، حيث كان الغاطس يفحصه
باستخدام ROV
ومن ثم ربما يربط خطًا به
ويستعيده بخط  مرة أخرى، دعونا
نتأكد من أننا نفهم أنه يبلغ
عمقه ميلين ونصف، وعدد قليل جدًا من
المركبات المأهولة أو البصلية يمكنها النزول إلى
هذا العمق،
عندما تضع خطًا هناك،
فهو خط طوله ميلين ونصف،
وبالتالي فإن السفينة السطحية  يصعد ويهبط،
وبالتالي فإن البحرية لديها هذا النظام الخاص
الذي يتم من خلاله توجيه الخط حول بكرة
فوق ممتص صدمات كبير بشكل أساسي،
لذا لا يوجد حمل مفاجئ على
الخط، ومرة ​​أخرى لديهم الكثير من
الخبرة في القيام بذلك.  إنها مجرد
مسألة توقيت
إذا كانوا لا يزالون على قيد الحياة ونحن ننظر
إلى تضاؤل ​​الأكسجين الذي
ينخفض ​​فيه الأكسجين الذي يصل إلى الدماغ وتلك
الزيادة في ثاني أكسيد الكربون
أه هو موقف مذعور للغاية تشعر فيه بأن
عالمك ينغلق عليك  آه، يبدو الأمر كما لو أن
كل شيء يصبح أضيق كما لو كان في نفق، إنه
شعور مروع أن الناس يشعرون
أنهم يموتون آه لا يمكنهم
تصديق أنهم
يفقدون حياتهم بهذه الطريقة المروعة
تصبح أضعف، تصبح مشوشًا،
تفقد التركيز، وتفقد
القدرة على الرؤية، لذا
تفقد رؤيتك المحيطية، إنها
طريقة مروعة للموت إذا كان الرجال الخمسة الموجودون
داخل تلك الغواصة يصدرون أصوات الضجيج هذه،
ونحن لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف ذلك بالتأكيد
ولكن إذا كانوا كذلك، فهذا يعني أنهم ما زالوا على
قيد الحياة
ولكن ما هي الظروف التي سيواجهونها
الآن، هل يمكنك أن تشرح لنا
ظروفهم أو كما تعلم هنا مرة أخرى
أن إمدادات الهواء الخاصة بهم مستنزفة وثاني
أكسيد الكربون  يتم البناء داخل
الكبسولة نفسها آه، نأمل أن تظل أجهزة غسل ثاني أكسيد الكربون
تعمل وتزيل
بعضًا من ثاني أكسيد الكربون
آه، لكن ما لم يتم نقلها إلى
السطح آه هنا في اليوم التالي، ستعرف
بحلول الغد آه أن الأمور تبدو
قاتمة، نعم لا يوجد هواء
العرض يذهب إلى الكبسولة أه لديهم
ما لديهم بالداخل وما
أحضروه معهم نعم نعم بالضبط وبالطبع
يبدو من السابق لأوانه
مناقشة هذا ولكن بالنظر إلى ما نعرفه
عن الأسئلة التي أثيرت في الماضي من قبل
أعضاء الصناعة والسابقين
موظفو Ocean Gate يتحدثون عن عدم وجود
شهادة لهذه الغواصة وبعض
المشاكل الأخرى، كيف من
المحتمل أن يغير هذا الحادث الطريقة التي
تدار بها هذه الرحلات الاستكشافية المتطرفة في المستقبل،
أعتقد أنهم إذا كانوا سيستمرون
في جلب سائحي المحيط السياحيين إلى
مواقف أه  بهذه الطريقة، سيتطلبون
شهادات أكثر صرامة،
وفي بعض الأحيان يكون ذلك أمرًا
جيدًا يخرج من موقف
مثل هذا، وهو مزيد من التنظيم الذي يعتمد على
السلامة، هنا عندما كنت في
البحرية، كان لدينا العديد من الشهادات،
وضوابط الجودة، وضمانات الجودة،
ولم تتمكن من العمل  على
نظام دعم الحياة أو
أحد المكونات المهمة لنظام الغوص
بدون عمليات عمل خاضعة للرقابة،
فهو صارم للغاية وإذا
لم يتبع هذا الرجل هذا البروتوكول،
فأعتقد أن الصناعة بحاجة إلى
التنظيم لذا فهي أكثر أمانًا لهذا النوع
من الصناعة،
حسنًا، دعنا فقط  آمل أن يتم العثور عليهم والعثور عليهم
سريعًا وإنقاذهم وإحضارهم
إلى السطح أه بالطبع الجميع ينتظرون
ويراقبون ريك أرمسترونج شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على التحدث معنا نقدر ذلك
شكرًا لك ونأمل أن يتم العثور عليهم